hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
elevating laboratory leadership
transforming your career and laboratory
through collaboration
i am jennifer woods of labrutz and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by
abbott to learn more visit core
laboratory
dot abbott we encourage you to
participate today
by submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
ann
cornreich head of the grand hospital de
charleroi laboratory medicine department
dr cornwright you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for your kind words of
introduction and hello to everyone in
attendance
today i will talk about my personal
experience in changing my career
and the laboratory but first
i would like to disclose that this
program is supported by abbott
and the views that i express in no way
constitute a claim
during this talk i will describe my
career transformation
and try and infer from it the key
qualities and training needed to
progress to lab manager
i would like to stress that this talk is
centered around a hospital lab
another private lab i will next explain
how the laboratory
can play a key role in driving strategy
through greater collaboration with the
hospital
in both clinical and financial
directions and then
i will review the current challenges and
trends in healthcare
and how they impact the lab
so i studied medicine because i was
interested in biology
and my father who was a cardiologist
recommended studies that would allow to
open more doors in the future during my
seven years of medical school
i was mostly attracted to surgery and
genetics
in my last year of training i had a
chance to work two months in a
hematology lab
and four months in the genetics lab
though i still loved surgery
i felt that the hematology lab was a
better suited career for me
and i enjoyed the work behind the
microscope combined with technical acts
such as bone marrow
aspirations and biopsies after my
five-year internship at the hazmat
university hospital of which three were
in hematology
i was hired there as a resident i
started teaching
laboratory hematology to the interns
who were training in our lab and also
taking on more responsibilities
then the head of our department asked me
to replace him for a five-day
residential seminar on leadership
this was a turning point for me it gave
me an interest in hr management
and a whole new perspective on my work
the hospital
and the way all the departments
interacted
then through a combination of
circumstances i took the head of the
cellular hematology lab
and reorganized its its activities and
manage the 10 lab technicians that
worked there
those were my first steps in management
after 17 years spent at the university
hospital and knowing that i didn't want
to pursue
an academic career i decided that it was
time to spread my ways
so i left the university environment for
a private hospital where i headed the
hematology lab
the hospital being small and the
activity reduced
it gave me time to explore new avenues
for my career
i became the president of scientific
society namely the belgian society for
advancement of cytometry
and completed a master's degree in
hospital management in evening classes
after 20 years of frontline hematology
work and long conversations with
my husband whose area of expertise is
administration
and hr management i realized that i was
ready to take a step back
while using all the experience i had
accumulated in the field of laboratory
medicine
that opportunity arose in the shape of
becoming the head of the laboratory
of a big private hospital of 1100 beds
to sum up this more personal part of the
talk i would say that what triggered my
career change was the desire to become
an active part of the decision making
process in every aspect of the lab and
apply logic
based on objective elements for its
management
i also strongly believe that what makes
the wealth of any business
is its human resources we therefore need
to provide training and instill
motivation to the staff
in this context i strongly recommend
this wonderful training tool
for hematology technicians and
clinicians alike
and invite you to take a look at this
hemet image program
i would like to emphasize that i don't
have any commercial interest
in this program
in order to infer the key qualities and
training needed to become a lab manager
we need to understand the role of the
clinical lab and that of the clinical
this is best described by the mayo
clinic they estimate that 60 to 70
percent
of all decisions regarding as patients
care and management
are based on laboratory test results
this also highlights the role of the
clinical biologist
which is crucial to improve the
laboratory in clinical interface
indeed the clinical biologists know the
circumstances in which the tests were
conducted from the acquisition of the
sample
until the send out of the results if
something along the way happened that
could have altered
the results it is a responsibility of
the clinical biologist to interpret
these results
so that the clinician would not jump to
the wrong conclusion
i believe that medicine is so vast and
so complex that it's not possible to be
omniscient
therefore it is a clinical biologist's
role to guide test utilization
in the fast-moving industry that is
diagnostic test development
it is a clinical biologist's job to stay
up to date
and provide physicians with the
information regarding the
characteristics
and the discriminatory power of
available tests
the same way that the physicians are
expected to build their clinical
approach on evidence-based medicine
the clinical biologists must visit their
approach on evidence-based laboratory
medicine
together with the physicians they must
help clarify the questions asked
in order to propose a relevant test best
suited to bring pertinent answers
only in this way leaving ego aside will
we effectively use the limited resources
available in healthcare
thus the mission of the laboratory is to
support the health care system through
providing fast
reliable and high quality results
offering state-of-the-art
testing in accordance with
evidence-based laboratory medicine
delivering medical support for adequate
detection diagnosis
and treatment of diseases as well as
disease prevention
and i will come back to that later and
due to the way
hospitals are families in belgium its
additional essential role
is to compensate for the hospital's
chronic underfunding
knowing all this i would like to share
my thoughts on what is needed to
successfully achieve good laboratory
management
as you've seen my journey was long and
gave me time to know myself
you may be faster than me but it will
still take time and you won't become a
manager overnight
it's important to examine your
motivation before taking on this
challenge and i think that you will have
a better chance of
chance of success if your main objective
is to do things better according to the
vision you have for the lab
for its workers and for its clients
their success and well-being will be
your success
and well-being it's paramount to know
what i call your playground rules
which will guide your choices and
decisions
for instance know the local rules and
regulations for the lab
for hr management and for equipment
acquisition
learn how the lab is financed and if i
have one piece of advice to give it
would be
always come prepared to meetings if you
don't
it's a waste of time and energy be
present
don't look at your phone listen don't
lose sight of
your objectives and don't be afraid to
act to ask questions
and if your questions have not been
answered don't make a decision so long
as things remain unclear
so now that you're the lab manager you
must define your vision
meaning the objectives you aim to reach
in my case
the aim for my lab is to become a lab of
excellence
iso 15 a189 certified
offering a wide very wide range of
relevant tests in order to control the
quality and speed
of the results transmitted to the
clinicians all consistent with the new
funding measures in the sector
in order to ensure its financial
profitability
define in your vision will give you the
guiding thread you need to follow
in all your projects
the lab is a major element of the
hospital and its organization
must be consistent with the organization
of the rest of the hospital
here i share with you the five pillars
that have been chosen in my hospital
and that are the same in all the care
polls
each poll defines its key performance
indicator
within each pillar it is your job as a
lab manager
to think about what you aim at for your
patients and for your prescribers which
are also your clients
you must also define your economical
objectives
and how you're going to reach them with
what process and what resources
and then you have to be able to measure
the effectiveness of everything you've
put into place
those will be the objective elements
that will guide your decision-making
process
so what are the carefuls i've been
talking about that define the hospitals
organizations
the care polls are functional units
grouping doctors and hospital
practitioners working together
they represent a significant volume of
activity
and are dedicated to a homogeneous group
of patients
for example geriatric patients or
a homogeneous group of pathologies for
example cancer
so they can be made up of one or several
departments
whether medical or surgical or both
in my hospital there are 10 clinical
care polls centered on systems
and three support care polls which are
the lab
the imagery department and the acute
care medicine department
the hospital's medical director and the
13 care pool heads
constitute a committee that meets every
two weeks to
discuss transversal projects
additionally this committee joined by
the directors committee
constitute the strategic committee of
the hospital
which meets twice a year and defines the
objectives for the hospital
and the necessary means to attain them
for example the decision to aim for the
accreditation of the hospital was taken
by the strategic committee
so what drove the reorganization of the
hospital in care polls
well mainly the evolution of medicine
and healthcare policies from individual
medicine to comprehensive health care
this requires multidisciplinarity in the
management of the patients
and therefore the idea was to gather a
set of clinical functions
to achieve that in an efficient and
harmonized way
and thus everyone reaps the benefits of
it of this organization
the patients through coordinated and
organized teams to take care of them
in a multidisciplinary approach the care
teams that can combine their resources
and skills and share their expertise
they have a more holistic view of their
patients and transversality is
facilitated
because there's a single point of
contact for each pole with a power of
decision
and finally the general practitioners
find satisfaction in this system
because their patients are assured the
best skills in the same entity
with multiple entry points for the same
pathology
for example for a herniated disc it's
the same pole
and the same coherent care path for also
an euro
so i want to share with you how our care
pose is structured
the lab is headed by either a medical
doctor or pharmacist
with a master's degree in a laboratory
medicine which we call a clinical
biologist
other clinical biologists with specific
competence in biochemistry
hematology or microbiology work in their
respective sectors
all are independent contractors thus
only have a functional authority with
the team managers
and the lab technicians working in their
respective sectors
together with the team managers the
clinical biologist organizes the
sector's activities and develop
and define the tests that are to be used
the hierarchical authority is exercised
by the labs executive manager
for the administrative aspects of hr
management
and by the scientific manager in
collaboration with the clinical
biologist for the scientific validation
of the test
all the lab activities are supported by
ancillary functions
such as quality assurance i.t and
various
administrative tasks the financial
engineer is provided by the financial
department of the hospital and supplies
financial data
on the lab's activities this allows
management based on objective and
measurable indicators
the pulse medical head the executive
manager
and the financial engineer constitute
the polls management trial
and that brings us to the financial
aspects of the job and understanding the
constraints we must face
the basic concept that underlies our
social security system in belgium is
solidarity
this solidarity is guaranteed because
all working people must contribute
to the system based on their salary and
all citizens contribute through this
taxes
thus the funding is provided by three
sources the state
the employers and the workers more
recently
a fourth source of financing is a
percentage of vat receipts and
additional excise duties
the national social security office
collects all those revenues
and distributes them among the seven
branches of social security
among those seven branches is the
compulsory insurance for all belgian
citizens for medical care and benefits
its budget was over 27 billion euros
last year
as everything in belgium all decisions
on the various aspects of the system are
the result of a compromise
in this case between the trade unions
the mutual insurance funds and the
employers organizations
the elementary pillars of our healthcare
philosophy
are quality and accessibility the
principle of free choice is paramount
this means that the patients can freely
choose their doctor
and the doctor can freely choose their
patients except in case of emergency
and has diagnostic and therapeutic
freedom
of course this has a cost and therefore
the key challenge
will be increasingly to provide health
care that is both affordable
and accessible while still maintaining
high quality
i would like to discuss with you the
various factors that threaten our
current model of healthcare financing
the aging of the populations concerns
baby boomers in our industrialized
countries
it means that the actual workforce
contributing to the social security
is less numerous than the population
they're mostly contributing
for and which are the biggest consumers
of healthcare
we also face an exponential growth of
healthcare demand
associated with new technological and
therapeutic developments
leading to drastic increase in
healthcare expenditure
also when health care becomes
digitalized and automated
new forms of pension arise in the health
care demand
and remuneration systems reforms are
necessary to ensure that the benefits of
digitalization
and automation through its network and
scale effects
will come into their own and finally
globalization has unforeseen effects
although freedom of movement is
undoubtedly a good thing
it allows our youth to seek work in
other countries
as shown in a previous slide our social
security covers all aspects of life
from birth to death as long as our
population
remains in belgium the beneficiaries of
our social security are also its
contributors
but when our youth leaves the country
after having been
subsidized for the university or
graduate studies
our system relying heavily on our
workforce becomes unbalanced
thus if nothing changes in our
healthcare fund
funding model it is imperative to
maintain the financial sustainability of
our healthcare system through efficiency
and effectiveness strategies we all
believe that our health is priceless
but it has a cost
i would now like to go more into the
details of the lab's financing system
today's system is the result of trials
and error and further fine-tuning
if all the financing were to be based
exclusively on itemization
the temptation would be strong for the
hospital to maximize
profits through pushing the physicians
to massively prescribe
tests thus increasing the burden on
health care expenditure
on the other hand if all the financing
were based exclusively on a flat rate
the temptation would be strong to
minimize test prescription
to maximize income while minimizing
expenses
but this attitude would be detrimental
to patient care
as already mentioned belgium is a
country of compromise
the current system combines 75 of
reimbursement as a flat rate
and 25 based on itemization
the limits uh abuse further
reimbursement is restricted by about 150
accumulation rules
for example if a resource site
sedimentation rate
and fibrino fibrinogen are prescribed
together
only one will be reimbursed and there's
also
about 90 diagnostic rules for example
homocysteine will only be reimbursed for
patients age less than
55 years old with clinical evidence of
vascular pathology
this implies an important responsibility
of the prescriber to provide clinical
information although this is rarely the
case
more recently no new flat rates were
introduced
for low variability care for example
there is one flat rate for the
for hip replacement and the distribution
of the medical
fees among the specialists involved in
the patient's care is determined by the
national institute for health care
and disability insurance the problem
is that fewer and fewer recent tests are
reimbursed
and thus the financial burden is being
transferred to the patients
this jeopardizes healthcare
accessibility one of the fundamental
principles of
our social security system
and to complicate things further because
as our local saying goes
why make things simple when you can make
them complicated
we have additional rules for
hospitalized patients
there are two more flat rates paid to
the lab for each patient admission and
one another one for each hospitalization
day
and this one based on the case mix of
the hospital
the annual bed shot for clinical biology
for clinical biology last year
was close to 1.5 billion euros thus
namely 5
of the overall health care budget
in the context of market changes and to
keep the system viable
healthcare institutions and laboratories
must adapt
this has led to the reorganization of
the hospital landscape
into networks facilitated by
digitalization to share patient data
the information and communication
technologies should prevent the
duplication of tests and services
but as mentioned before this evolution
must be accompanied by reforms
in the financing working groups
designated by the authorities have been
tasked
with readjusting the nomenclature for
medical care in general and for clinical
biology in particular
one of the main projects is to find
financial incentives
to switch from a sick model to a
prevention model
the rationale being that the longer
people remain healthy
the less financial burden they will be
on the health care system
we see today with the kovic pandemic how
hard it is to convince the population to
take adequate
preventive measures and namely
vaccinations
which would greatly release pressure on
every country's health care systems
people have increased expectations of
science and have forgotten that before
massive vaccination programs around the
world
many people died of infectious diseases
i could go on for hours but this is not
the point of today's talk
but it illustrates the importance of
prevention in any health care system
and its cost effectiveness another way
to increase cost effectiveness
is to integrate the rational use of
resources
and quality in our fee-for-service
system
and lastly the current trend in
laboratory medicine
is to consolidate multiple labs into a
single one within a network
of hospitals
i would like to discuss with you this
last idea and review its pros and cons
as i said in the beginning my talk is
centered around
hospital labs and it's important to keep
that in mind for this discussion
we all know that the ideas behind the
consolidation is to increase the
critical mass of tests
to go past a break-even point and
increase profitability
the theory is that we will achieve a
decreased cost per test
thanks to an increased turnover a
rationalization of hr
and economies of scale that business
model might be adequate for private labs
that don't have the constraints of
hospital
labs in our setting consolidation
implies the multiplication
of small emergency labs because
hospitals treat patients 24
7. the possible benefits of economies of
skill
would have to be reinvested in triage
transport
and support of the emergency labs with
the consequence of a lower specimen
quality
due to transport logistical difficulties
and longer turnaround times redundancy
of testing platforms are essential in a
hospital lab
as is optimal communication between
sectors for example
if we receive a limited amount of
cerebral spinal fluid
the same tube will go first to
microbiology then hematology and finally
to chemistry in the same way
a direct contact between hematology and
the blood bank
will speed up the bleeding patients
management
and we need additional human resources
to cover
this time slots outside working hours
i would thus propose an alternate model
in the hospital setting
i believe that each hospital of the
network should keep its
in-house lab with all the main routine
activities
which include all the emergency tests
this would allow the preservation of the
best possible turnaround time
and service to the hospital clinicians
with the expertise of the clinical
biologists remaining in the hospital
indeed the bulk of the cost is not due
to the size of the analyzers
but is mainly due to the region to the
reagents
consumables and disposables disposables
which are all activity related
and human resources who are already
present 24
7. i think that the hospitals in the
network
should agree to mutualize specialized
non-urgent tests in a single site
this is where consolidation is the most
cost effective
without affecting quality or service i'm
thinking of activities such as
autoimmunity allergology mass
spectrometry
etc
and this brings us to the end of this
talk i would like to conclude with the
world health organization's definition
of the continuum of care
which is the offer of a complete service
array from hospitals to home care
and which requires all medical and
social services within the community
to be brought together laboratory
medicine plays a central role in this
continuum of care
and i think i demonstrated that our
social security
security in belgium aims at offering
this continuum of care despite new
funding challenges
but in order for this continuum of care
to be a reality
the patient has to stand in the center
of the healthcare supply chain
and for all the healthcare initiatives
to converge towards them
this implies that for every patient and
for every type of pathology
the most adequate and available
treatment should be suggested
regardless of profitability for any
level
or actor the most important selection
criterion
must be the patient's needs
i prepared this slide for further
reading and to give you some food for
thought
thank you for your attention and i will
be happy to answer your questions
thank you dr cornreich for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen we'll answer as many
of your questions
as we have time for okay let's get
started
our first question is
does it mean that there are no medical
laboratory scientists working with the
care poll
yes that's right the way the
laboratories are organized in belgium
the there are no medical laboratory
scientists working
they're replaced by the clinical
biologist which
uh has either a medical degree
or pharma pharmacist degree and the
specialty takes uh
five years of master study uh to get to
that level after having done
either medical school bingham becoming a
doctor
or uh becoming a pharmacist uh then
in some university hospital labs there
may be some
uh medical laboratory scientists but
usually there
there aren't any
thank you dr cornright okay our next
question
is is the idea of the care polls a
standard in belgium
or is this an innovative program that
your institution has created and
implemented
implemented okay a care portals are not
a
novel idea other hospitals have them too
but never in such an extensive way as we
did in our hospital
sometimes they just combine a few
specialties together and call them poles
but in our hospital all medical
specialties
are regrouped in distinct care pools
and like i said we have 13 in our
hospital
and so this is really something
innovative because there are no more
medical departments that are independent
of the care pool
thank you again dr kornwreck our next
question
is in an ideal world how do you envision
the laboratory clinician partnership
what do you think is necessary to reach
this ideal
this is a very good question and
unfortunately we don't live in an ideal
world
this is why also in belgium and in other
european countries
we have this specialty
of laboratory medicine for doctors and
pharmacists
so that the clinician
can discuss cases
equal to equal with uh the laboratory
doctor or pharmacist because we had
the same training and we went through
this
um also uh clinical
training before becoming laboratory
doctors and so
this allows the discussion to be on the
same level
so in the ideal world the clinician um
and this is what the authorities are
trying to finance
the clinicians have to ask the questions
okay i have this patient that has
this such and such uh symptoms and signs
uh how can the lab help me
get to the diagnosis uh in the best
way use the best test available
how do i interpret the results what are
the possible
interferences that we'll have with uh
those tests those
would be the ideal way of working and
the most
uh cost effective way also
all right thank you again uh we've got
another question
about the care polls uh was there um
were there any barriers to the
implementation of these care polls
no they there wasn't there weren't any
barriers this was
discussed at length with uh
ambassadors so we had a strategic
meeting
with ambassadors from
each uh uh
poll that that that we thought were
going to come into existence
so in the ambassador for each for was
this uh designated
by all the departments that were
supposed to be in that
poll and those ambassadors uh
participated in the first strategic
meeting with the
directors committee and that allowed to
um to determine
which poles were going to come into
um into being
and uh what were expected of the careful
heads
and so the ambassadors went back to the
different departments that were that
were included in their polls
and then elections were done in each
poll to elect
the polls head the the only
difference is that when a poll
encompasses several departments
then if there was an election but when a
poll
is a unique department like for example
the laboratory poll
the head of the department was
automatically the head of the poll
okay great thanks again dr kornreich her
next question is
what did your previous structure look
like before care polls
and were there any problems with that
yes
so the previous structure were like
i think most hospitals we had
about 30 to 40 medical departments
for each medical specialty and
so the problem with that is that we
to to go forward
all together you have to and we had
meetings with all the head of
departments but that means having
meetings with a lot of people
and it's sort of it's it was sort of
chaotic and also um
the hospitals is organized in such a way
that we have bilateral meetings between
the head of the department
and the medical director
the general director and the financial
director of the hospital
twice a year where we would show
the annual financial financial
statements of
each department and discuss
future projects and investments that we
wanted to do
inside each head each department but
that meant also
for the directors to to meet with
uh twice a year with 30 to 40 different
different departments regrouping
everything in polls
first of all allowed to limit those
meetings
and to have already an idea inside the
poll
because things are already managed
inside each poll
including uh the the investments
so there was already an arbitrage inside
the poll
and then they were presented during
those bilateral meetings
twice a year uh to the directors for the
directors is also allowed
uh to have a general view of all the
medical activities in the hospital
um in a very short uh
and concentrated time and
to have uh to better guide
the the strategic aim of of the hospital
and of the medical projects
and like i said we also have meetings of
the
head for the paul hebs committee um
twice a month which also allows us to
discuss transversal
projects between each between all the
poles
and that is done in the presence of the
medical director and so he can bring
back the ideas to the general director
and to the directors committee and we
can go forward all together
so that's oh that's a pretty effective
way of managing
the medical activities of the hospital
great thanks again um dr kornreich for
that really
in-depth answer appreciate that okay and
our next question
what is the composition of the
scientific commission and
what do they actually advise in the lab
uh the composition of the scientific
commission i don't see
what you mean by that
monica could you maybe elaborate a
little bit on your question
perhaps um i think maybe she means who
all
is as you know in the maybe in the poll
or in the commission
um like what departments do they come
from
do you have i think that might be what
monica means let me move on to another
question and maybe that monica will
you know elaborate a little bit more the
next question
do you see a future in the eu where
health care may be handled the same way
across all countries or will countries
continue to maintain their own health
care approaches
well again i think this is a question
where
uh there is the utopia of
having maybe everything done the same
way everywhere in europe
but the reality of of things is that
all the countries in europe have
difference in living standards
and uh in demographic pressure
and medical services and technologies
and that would make it very
difficult to have a homogeneous way
of um of handling healthcare
uh throughout europe there are probably
what things what that we can do together
and i think
again the kovit pandemic showed us that
it's necessary
to get together for
infectious diseases which no no borders
but maybe for other healthcare issues
those still have to be handled within
each country
as an example in belgium we have a we
have nine
ministers for health care because
the country is so divided between
communities and regions and different
languages and
it shows how difficult it is within a
country to have a uniform way of
managing health care and doing that at
the european level
uh seems to me like something that would
be very difficult to achieve
yeah so much that comes into play there
right yes
okay next question here dr cornright
uh as you indicated more charges are
becoming the responsibility of the
patient
do you have a private insurance option
in belgium for people
to use to cover those expenses
okay so i i talked about the compulsory
health care insurance in belgium which
covers
most of the health care expenditure but
there are private insurance options
either proposed by the um
[Music]
the mutual um care
uh because there's a there's still a
level between the
federal reimbursement and the patient
which are the mutual funds so mutual
funds can offer complement
complementary additional
health care insurance private insurance
but there are also
[Music]
private insurance funds that can also
propose private insurance those
insurance usually cover
hospitalization and in their coverage
they usually cover
one month before hospitalization and
three months after
but they will uh control that uh the
expenditure that the patient had is
in um is in uh
um it is within
the pathology that was treated uh
during hospitalization so they won't
cover all
the outpatients costs
a specific insurance for outpatient
costs i don't think
they exist in belgium there are some
outpatient costs such as
certain medication or
yeah i think or maybe some
uh apparatus that the patient might need
but that usually goes through the
the expert doctor of the mutual fund
so you have to submit um a claim
to to get reimbursement uh which won't
be automatically covered by the
the compulsory um health insurance that
all veterans have
i hope that answers the question
okay great thank you again uh dr
kornreich
it looks like that's uh all that we have
time for today
do you have any final comments for our
audience today dr cornright
uh no i hope i hope you found the the
uh the talk interesting there are a lot
more information
on the slides than what i uh what i
explained
during the talk so i hope you you will
find
uh by rereading the slides of answers to
questions that maybe didn't have a
chance to
to ask during this q a and thank you for
attending
and thank you for your questions
well thank you again dr cornwright for
your time today
and for your important research we would
also like to thank labyrinth and our
sponsor abbott
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye